[Music]
if you go back to K N we know we had a
force on the head wrapping around me and
we know we had a force on his condad on
the on the bottom side of his lever
going in the different direction of that
and we know that we had a force that
moved that whole
foot do you understand so we had his uh
deconstruction of his basic support So
regardless of his athleticism RAB is
going to work on him his his only choice
is how badly
that's it okay got it so what you can do
is you can reverse engineer that look
like a forward
roll let me identify these three
elements okay got got it and those three
elements will work together as one
element try in philosophy again okay so
um let us
take
[Music]
um let's just start simple okay so I'm
going to move something that's actually
first your first concern I'm going to
move it into
the fourth concern okay so this hand
here how many spirals do I have with my
tabaki two does this look like the
inward
spiral so it's the outward spiral so my
elbow's going to go
in I'm not I'm he's not pushing and I
get out of the way
okay my elbow's going to go in you you
see what it's doing to his body okay and
now I'm going to continue this
[Music]
arm he's going to come
forward and this arm keeps going around
stay there and I'll give you that last
Vector is right
here so you can see his arm
it's going this
[Music]
way got
it it's not going
here it's it's still got more to do and
then I throw
here that's not what's
happening so my elbow rolls
in and I move into the
space
is your CQ projection
line so we'll take everything
out you're going to have to do the foot
work but you can do it even
[Music]
Loosely that's the lift that you were
feeling
okay go back to what you learned on the
cooku projection what makes it
easier when shoulder goes what when
shoulder no in what makes that c
projection
easier keep them going forward what more
the head can come the more the head can
go
where blow so you do it
here this is going to be
heavier
so as I
go you have to wait for his head to get
low okay let's do that it's an iy hand
because it's a yinyang world it starts
iy goes C it starts Yin goes y okay try
so my my my hand is doing the spiral do
you
see it's not going to change shape this
is not a spiral that's a circle because
my elbow didn't come in you see it going
like
this that's a circle can you guys see
that okay and likewise I go here cool
cool that's a weird spot SP is going
that
way so I have
to keep the
shape keep the
shape so you can see this way step into
the space you created keep it going
forward lower it his head boom once this
head gets low enough for your projection
capacity you change it one two keep it
going
Bo okay let's go a point we have to make
is that although it looks like I'm I'm
going flat on this circle I don't want
to do that because I'm going to activate
the outer
Del so elbow comes
in and my my arm is continually to try
to turn that
way go back a little bit it's not that I
started and then I try to bring this out
with my outer Delta I'm trying not
to okay so it starts to turn and I keep
moving I don't think you're going to see
the
over so here don't start bringing this
arm flat on that
Circle
turn keep it turning I'm not going to
start going here's where you guys start
to pull it just keep it turning it can't
go anymore and that's when you're moving
in
[Music]
okay let's clean that part
up all right so now we'll go to the
other hand okay so let's let's just
debrief a little okay so this this arm
was going out this is the outward spiral
in yinyang world you know the other
one's going to do the inward spir okay
this
one went
down and then
out so the other one's going to go up
and
in okay don't change this it does what
it was always doing so to go up and
in I'm going to come come up Palm
up Palm
up and then there's your iners
spiral so you watch my two hands this
one was going this
way this one's going that way they move
his whole body
together so it goes
up and I want to focus
well let me just have you try that first
the two arms move together so think
about this still doing what it was
doing
all right two hands moving together
let's
try now your ego trip typ mind is going
to go oh arm arm break here you get it
so you're thinking hyper extension you
feel that and then either he goes or I'm
going to break his arm right so you go
like you're thinking
that do you understand that's not
you can't throw someone with a joint
thread you might break it now you're not
throwing them does that make sense okay
so you're not trying to break the
arm what I'm going to
do if you pay
attention you go in here his elbow is
now on
top you get that and there's my angle of
cancellation so we have this angle
cancellation where I create a zone of s
around this
corner right and then you have this
angle look same thing on this side okay
so his elbow's on top It's Not
underneath so when I come around I'm not
even on the elbow you see that okay
because what I'm trying to do is get
around on the in inside and trying to
get around on the inside
which will happen once this arm
continues to do it I'm going to get on
the inside feel feel okay and now
because this arm had to end up down
that's where that spiral creates the
adhesion do you see and so this this
adhesion is going to lower his
head
boom I'm trying to get to the
inside and that spiral is going to lower
his head so don't I'm not going to
project you okay and I'll go slow and
you'll feel what I'm talking about okay
so you can see there's no I'm not on
your joint can you tell that okay so
we'll do it
slow okay and with this arm here I'm
going to aim his head down try to get
back up
I told you not to
roll one two I want this
down don't roll you're so trained
you shouldn't roll because I didn't do
the tops of Turvy I didn't kick over the
top you
understand I'm not going so fast that
you have to reconcile the
M lift up come back lift
up
try so uh now what I have to do is well
let's just we'll do one more on the on
the other arm okay so as you're coming
in there was a dow to it but the spiral
has an inwardness too so you want some
inwardness as we get to the fourth part
that's going to prove relevant okay so
we'll do one more on
this I know I'm going to have down I
know I'm not trying to break his arm in
fact I'm trying to get inside where
there is no joint okay and I know that's
aiming down but it has some some
inwardness to it because it is the
inward spiral
okay so if if I if I took this
out and just hooked
here boom and slamed someone down Bo
he's not going to roll but IO person
rolls do you get it
because the the the throwing geometry is
not there there's no Topsy turby element
there's just a downward element okay so
you have to remember don't start
emphasizing only the what you think is
the Y arm because at the end this
becomes the young arm okay so you're
in P
pop
you can you feel the downward now
you all right let's we got to take a
step back so we already talked about the
uh inward
kazushi um and I'm going to go back to
it on the fourth on the fourth element
okay but on all of your throwing
architectures you should get what what I
now call a body lock okay um so let's do
this hand and I'll take that inward
spiral okay you see and I'm not going to
step
here and then accelerate him
[Music]
backwards there's going to be a
part where between this pressure you see
and this enter here I have him locked in
place
okay
that's what that's what you're always
trying to feel for the
lot and then this way I can make his
body spin around me like in
kiten
or here
ID don't go here but same thing I'm
going to get my hip in
there so I get the same lock between
this energy my Ed me so I
can TR in place
you understand then he can go around me
okay
um same thing in this technique so when
you come
around this will those in the
front so my lock is going to
be
here so I'll take the arms out so you
can see the bottom
triangle of the hips
okay Bo I'm going to move in here I'll
push this leg out so this this leg will
come on my kind of
cushy what
I'm
what I'm
doing there this triangle is your
opening and you see it helps generate
the
top okay so leave the arms as dead as
possible in on your me you're going to
do that bottom part of this triple
attack okay let's try the fourth element
because it's not impossible to do the
third element without this fourth
element but you will find it if you were
struggling with it as it was this might
help you
okay just as our ego triart mind sees
the arm break and some guy doesn't want
his arm broken and he goes forward all
you see a 12 to6
line and you see a guy
pushing so you
turn and then you accelerate him where
he's
going that's not
it so he kind not
it he at some point he's coming at me
right at some point I have him coming at
me but I I get out of the way and I make
this go around me got
it the front kazushi is always going to
do this so I'm not going to
go this
way he's going to go around me and I I I
hesitant to give you a Direction but
maybe you'll just notice he's not going
to go that
way
that's going to make that hip be on
there
okay can you see that
okay
um so let's split them out in half cuz
you're going to need more room okay here
we go so some some people just kind let
go that 126 line so you're you're going
to go well I know he threw him North
okay so the right angle here or you're
entering over here like before and then
you're
going that's not it
okay different from element three I
taught in static was I had to do it I
had to put my hip
there that's not very iido I'm going to
put you see how we're not touching you
see and as we start to enter he goes on
the turn look his hips are in the right
place right now you see and so that's
where I
enter there you see that so I can't
enter where I
was it's somewhere over here
okay and then you would keep the
continuous so I want you to think about
that and then the other thing is as he's
pushing on me he's pushing on
me that push I keep going
around you understand don't stop
it don't go here then it waits for you
so you can
enter the the push just keeps flowing
around you get it so use those two
things so you can get who disc
continuous continuous motion okay let's
try common
mistake and it really stems from being
attached to the 126 line and it might
carry over into this actual front
kazushi pattern okay and that is uh your
ten
con do you're going like this and then
you would enter because you need all
that acceleration to get them to go
forward
okay you get it so you're here like this
you do kind of turn here he falls there
and then you come in but that's not
going to work for this one cuz cuz
you're not you're not generating a
single pivot point so he can't go around
you okay so
so then the other common mistake is on
an a choreograph you is you would
enter 10 con and then you get 6 in of
EDI and then he would throw himself
okay ten con does not
mean enter and then being comma over
here that's not what ten conies ten comp
means just to change to change the
relationship okay
so right now my right hip's my front hip
you see so when I turn now my left hip's
my front hip that's ten con okay that if
you're like I can't let go ten con and
this is how to better understand it okay
so now I I put my other foot in the box
with this hip forward some of you have
your foot right in the back and you're
not in this but you're over here and
this is not a clear front hip so it's
very hard now to cross across this hip
okay this hip has to go in the back do
you see and then I can make my circle
around so as I'm going you see it's
easyy watching my feet
boom okay then now my this hip is
clearly forward this hip is back and now
I can enter on my usual curve on all of
my techniques right so it's over
here okay got it so let's clean up that
ten con go